muy buen día para ti revolvió el anuncio
presidencial realizado en cadena
nacional el presidente de república ha
emitido uno lo que ha sido uno de los
principales focos de la protesta en este
país y ha sido como tú has mencionado la
reducción de 10 centavos a dólar tanto
como para la gasolina extra y eco país y
digo la forma 10 centavos de oro horas
para el diesel esto significa una
reducción de
226 millones de dólares anuales y por el
cuál ha dicho que está pendiente cuáles
son las principales manifestaciones de
los grupos que se encuentran todavía en
el día número 15 de las manifestaciones
en el ecuador por su parte la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas de ecuador leonidas iza ha
dicho que los avances han sido parciales
por parte de la respuesta del ejecutivo
en nacional hasta ahora se siente una
tensa calma pero hay que destacar
también que el ejecutivo nacional ha
dicho que mantendrá la autorización del
uso progresivo de la fuerza en cuanto a
la retención de las manifestaciones se
siente en este momento una tensa calma
pueden verse todas algunos grupos y
cuerpos de seguridad pero para el día de
hoy también se espera que continúa
algunos eventos la noche de ayer la
unidad quizás todavía llevaba a mantener
las movilizaciones en las calles es que
también se están realizando algunos
festivales culturales mientras que el
ejecutivo nacional mantiene su discurso
en cuanto a preservar el orden también
asegurar que de los 20.000 manifestantes
que se mantenían en la ciudad de quito
ya quedan aproximadamente 4.500 eso
quiere decir que también los eventos y
protestas se han reducido de 700 que se
producían a diario a 150 que se están
produciendo en este momento pero el
presidente de la confederación de
nacionalidades del ecuador también ha
viajado por los distintos
localidades y barrios de la ciudad
capital para mantener vivo el mensaje de
que todavía las paralizaciones se
mantienen en la ciudad capital esto
también se relaciona con el pedido
abiertamente que ya se realiza por
algunos sectores de las confederaciones
indígenas a mantener el paro y sobre
todo estar pendiente a lo que se realice
en la asamblea nacional de él del pedido
de destitución del presidente de la
republica que se suspende hasta el día
martes a las 11 de la mañana